how's gone Braz - Peter pop but today's
Friday's better pop we're going to
review fine art I ask you brothers to
post on Facebook and I'm gonna review
your fan I that you sent to me also
before we begin I have trimmed my
mustache since this episode I know
everyone's gonna comment about it I know
everyone is gonna comment about it you
can stop right now and apologize if you
did I know you did
it's pretty okay I guess now this this
is art how's it going bro Spanish paper
I asked you on facebook submit your fine
art I'm gonna review it let's let's
check it out these two were awesome by
the way I'm sorry someone point out that
it they thought it was Hitler I do I do
have a terrible mustache
I I'm not gonna lie I made you look like
an alien though I see that this is
actually you but I made it look like
Jack they totally does look like Jack
you're right this is supposed to be
chicken my chicken well this is Kyoto
nation that's actually cool thank you
I've always wanted to be ancient your
fan art chibi Peter pie there always has
to be at least one Skipton skip says
skip it took eight hours damn that's
dedication I think I haven't spent that
long in a video I sing this one yeah
that was cool it's good good job I drew
a character from Naruto I'm not Naruto
characters I'm not I'm just not I'm
sorry I'm very nice though
ah skip balance cute I like this one
it's very it's cute I like that pink
coloring too are these all playthrough
is that have we done damn we don't wait
too many
let's Golda very creative oh I seen this
one this is awesome
I love how they've even detailed the
bulge in the crunch should be a little
bigger if you know what I mean
huh wait no I'm sorry let me see this
I'm sorry but this [ __ ] sucks I drew
some walking addenda characters thank
you thanks I love it ten out of ten
those headphones are [ __ ] out I wish
I had headphones like that okay so the
more we scroll down the more you really
go to the the dark corners this is not
even me what am I looking at right now
what am I looking at why are you doing
this here is a drawing of Jack I did cuz
he's cuter than you'll ever be
oh now we're never now we're really
getting what's wrong what's wrong what
happened I thought this would be a cute
innocent video what am I looking at okay
now we're getting now this what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] the super here we did on the
podcast we always roleplay at the end of
the episodes and I don't even remember
what the [ __ ] we were doing here but
there's a guy in latex suit screaming
yah killing dinosaurs there it is that's
pretty that's pretty cool thank you
thank you aren't that's awesome and
we're back and we're back
we're definitely back but thank you for
watching this video keep submitting fat
activity hash tag fan pants art boots
that's shitty I'll think of a better
hashtag but that's all for me for now
and as always stay awesome this
well that was sick bro